hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and
just checking in on you just checking in
to see how your week's going
hope uh hope it's going all right i'm
actually up early here it's 5
24 in the morning we just had a [ __ ]
earthquake out here
um and i got to tell you something i
am pretty upset with the
of how complacent i am with earthquakes
now
i was in bed of course you know i'm an
old man
i go to bed around oh 7 30 7 35
get up at 10 to take a little geritol of
course my bladder starts talking around
1 30. no i'm kidding
and i went to bed at lake midnight all
right i still got a little life left in
me
um so i'm sleeping as you do 4 30 in the
morning unless you're a trucker
trying to make that we're trying to make
that deadline i did driving on [ __ ]
night ain't no traffic out there and
denny's open 24 7.
um son you know
[ __ ] bed starts shaking i wake up i
hear something
something smashed downstairs in the
kitchen
and at no point
did i ever think that well what if my
house collapsed and all my loved ones
you know are trapped i didn't even think
that i just laid there i was just like
oh it's an earthquake
[Laughter]
wasn't there some [ __ ] up experiment
where they stuck a a
rat in a uh in
in boiling water if you stuck it in
boiling if you just dropped it in
boiling water immediately jumped out and
tried to get out
but if you stuck it in there and you
slowly increase the heat it would stay
in there until it [ __ ] died
i don't know if it was a rat i don't
remember if it was an octopus i don't
know what the [ __ ] they used
do you realize how [ __ ] up scientists
sometimes did they actually sit there
killing animals
to try and answer their [ __ ]
questions
all right everybody we have a rat and uh
over here we have a
boiling pot of water and over here we
have a uh room temperature
bottle of water a pot of water and what
we're gonna do is we're gonna drop this
rat
into this boiling water and there's a
bunch of people
standing there with clipboards and
[ __ ]
those [ __ ] lab coats on and you know
one of them has to be going like dude i
don't want to
don't [ __ ] i don't want to watch you put
a [ __ ] rat in boiling water
i don't want to listen to this [ __ ]
thing screaming or whatever the hell a
rat does
but they don't say anything they don't
want to rock the boat
you know they got they got they gotta
tow the company lie
and no matter how much those rats suffer
they're not gonna say a [ __ ] word
because they're chasing the carrot and
the carrot is
the [ __ ] the robot human sex dolls
that they're making a couple floors up
that's what they're working towards so
they can air quote
work on that project
just basically go [ __ ] a bunch of sex
robots
so these rats die day in and day out
in that classic experiment that at this
point i think is a trope
um how hypocritical is this because i
wanted to [ __ ]
take this scale that you get from
stamps.com and drop it on that mouse
or that [ __ ] actually the rat
the rat really is i see why they made
ratatouille you know what i mean because
mice are [ __ ] cute they really are
they're [ __ ] adorable
and it's something that i i really do
not like seeing i don't like seeing
those videos where [ __ ] snakes eat
them
but you know something happens to a rat
you're like yeah [ __ ] that thing you
know
somebody tells on somebody they're a
[ __ ] rat
well i guess a mouse isn't good either
right quiet as a church mouse
christ you sat there you're like a
[ __ ] mouse
[Laughter]
why don't you learn to speak up for
yourself i mean both of them
really at some point you know maybe they
can jump on this [ __ ] woke movement
too you know
white women can somehow attach
themselves to it like they got some sort
of [ __ ] issue
um then why can't the mice and the rat
get it ow bill what are you talking
about i'll tell you what i'm talking
about i've been reading up on the war of
and the [ __ ] information on it
and the vibe of each article
is just wildly different
you know if i read a lot of the
americanized versions
what was going on was england and france
were going at it as they always do
you know you can't get along with one
another
listen everybody in england knows that
the french are better
you know they got better food better
culture better artists
you know it wasn't until you know
the white bands over there stole from
the black guys the blues guys over here
that england became cool that's
basically it i mean it was never really
cool
i'm just [ __ ] with you guys i'm just
like right oh you told
um i don't know anything about any of
this [ __ ]
um anyway they're going at it
okay france has this little fella named
napoleon
you know and to this day you know if
you're a little [ __ ] and you're running
your mouth in a [ __ ] bar oh he's got
a napoleon complex
you know if you were a little [ __ ] you
should be like what oh you mean that
legendary
general
i said it down here um
you got a napoleon con complex i love
the fact
that there's been all of these lunatics
throughout history grabbing land
enslaving people doing [ __ ] horrible
stuff
but you know as long as they were
regular height they were just considered
out of their [ __ ] mind or
a great general depending on who won
and who you were listening to right
so here comes another just [ __ ]
lunatic trying to expand and do all of
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then there's ah he's doing it
because he's short
making all short people seem like you
got to keep an eye on him
all right those little [ __ ]
they're so annoyed with being short hey
those little [ __ ] will start a war
that'll bring down your goddamn country
so anyway i don't know what napoleon did
i think he was yet another dumb person
that tried to go
into russia and spread himself too thin
and got the [ __ ] kicked out of him
right wait let's see how tall is hitler
what is with
short guys taking their armies into
[ __ ]
russia and getting their asses kicked
you know here's my question for people
in russia listen to this
is the third time going to be the charm
you defeated the first two short guys
but can you handle the third
and three is a magic number if i
remember from [ __ ] schoolhouse rock
all right
uh jesus christ some of the [ __ ] because
of this podcast
in my search engine adolf hitler height
you actually have his height and his
weight he was five
nine he was not short
five nine was decent height back then
is there any picture of him where he
looks even remotely amused
okay let's add this to my search honey
adolf hitler smiling
i just realized that this is the one
this is pr these are probably the photo
oh my god he looks like moe howard
um these are the photos that they
probably
show at like white supremacist meetings
anyway what about a guy i gotta tell you
he actually has a really nice smile
he gives an entirely different this poor
[ __ ] kid
he's [ __ ] crouched down giving this
kid a little hug
these are disturbing what is he laughing
about look at this he's got his hair
combed straight down i swear to god he
looks like [ __ ] mohawk
then there's a weird split picture of
him smiling and they've
added gandhi in this one you got to love
the internet it's just so [ __ ] nuts
the fact that i could look up hitler's
adolf hitler smiling videos
and hd footage 217 adolf hitler
smiling photos these are all on getty
images by the way
photo of hitler hugging jewish girl
wrote this is just getting weirder and
weird
astonishing photo of hitler smiling and
hugging
jewish girl rosa bernal
naino i don't know what i'm saying this
is a jarring photo evidently
what's the story little girl was
portrayed as adolf hitler's favorite
they shared the same birthday april 20th
she called him uncle hitler
jesus christ and was known as the
furious child
see this is one of these things is this
[ __ ] real is somebody just [ __ ]
with me
at a time when nazi leaders jesus christ
i need to eat something sorry about my
stomach grumbling here
at a time when the nazi leaders was was
being
presented to the world as a kindly
figure his personal photo
photographer frequently snapped pictures
of the two of them holding hands
exchanging kisses
on the cheek or just smiling each other
hitler refused to cut off contact with
the girl even after
he was told she had a jewish grandmother
i mean if this guy isn't one of the
weirdest [ __ ]
weird i would say is a little light so
anyway i was
reading these [ __ ] articles so
the short guy in france who couldn't
handle the fact
that he couldn't look down a woman's
shirt when she bent over he was still
looking at the [ __ ] dark side of the
moon of her titties
you know then to compensate for that
i don't understand how winning a [ __ ]
war makes him feel taller
or fighting a [ __ ] war
um anyway
so england and france are going at it
as they always did so then
because they were being [ __ ] babies
about it the same way club owners used
to do this [ __ ] when two club owners had
a [ __ ]
fight then they would go to the comics
and go hey you can't [ __ ] work for
this other [ __ ] guy if you work for
this other [ __ ] guide and you're not
[ __ ] working my [ __ ]
you know blah blah blah then you had to
make a decision they did that to america
according to some of this [ __ ]
right it was basically they both said
hey
if you trade with the person that i'm
fighting then we're [ __ ] at war with
you and we're gonna do all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] to you and all of these threats
so we were stuck in the middle so i
think thomas jefferson said well then
[ __ ] it we're not trading with either
one of you and then our economy [ __ ] the
bed
so then everybody was screaming and
yelling like they do nowadays
except there was no internet so they
were running around and then night
shirts holding up a [ __ ] lantern
i don't know you know yelling at
somebody
saying we got to pick a side we got to
do something
oh [ __ ] yo um
and then they were [ __ ] you know
england was breaking all these maritime
laws boarding our ships
and then some articles say if they found
an english deserter
they would take the person and stick
them back into their navy
and then other ones are suggesting that
they would just take americans and make
them f
like kidnap them and make them fight for
their navy so i don't know what's going
on there
and then other ones say that because
britain and france were going at it
we used it as this opportunity to try
and expand
and then go into canada and try and
claim some [ __ ]
all i know is we we lost some big fights
we
won in baltimore
right where francis uh uh freddie scott
key whatever the [ __ ] his name is
he wrote the national anthem he actually
ripped it off he wrote the lyrics
but it was to a [ __ ] uh an old
british drinking song
he went jimmy page on him you know
butter
i see the old glory [ __ ] sitting
there
in the [ __ ] bombs burst it in the air
it's like out on the tiles out on the
tiles i guess was an old british
drinking song i'm out on the tiles i had
a little drink and
something i don't know i heard jason
barnum singing one time right so they
basically did that
and then there's this whole [ __ ]
thing that alludes to
uh indentured servants
and slaves having no refuge in the
second verse
so this is just some dumb song he went p
diddy he took a [ __ ] hit
song and he just changed the [ __ ]
lyrics right not saying that's all pete
did he did what i'm just saying
you know um
anyway he did the every breath you'd
take remix
and he wrote the [ __ ] song and then a
hundred years later
it became the national anthem evidently
i don't know what the national anthem
was
before that um so anyway we tried to
expand
out to the west and then british britain
tried to turn
it's funny they said they tried to turn
native americans against uh
white settlers expanding it's like i
think they were already there
mentally i would think um i don't know
but all i know is we won some big ones
we won
in baltimore we won the battle of
orleans
there was one other one that i already
forget but then we got our asses
kicked up in canada
with tecumseh and [ __ ] the british
guys right
and they kicked our ass all the way they
took detroit
this is [ __ ] unbelie i never heard of
this [ __ ] right
they took detroit and then it took
another
u.s general to go in there
um
and [ __ ] defeat him and reclaim the
northwest territory which
is what we now know is ohio indiana
illinois michigan and
wisconsin like i guess we lost that
um and then the biggest one is they came
into dc
basically the war with france ended and
then
the most powerful navy in the [ __ ]
universe at the time
was then able to turn their full
attention
to us they came into the into washington
dc
took over the state capitol went into
the white house
had a big feast and then burnt the
[ __ ] place down
i don't know why they ignore this movie
in hollywood
this story in hollywood it's [ __ ]
amazing
um so anyway i'm going to read a little
i'm going to read
up on little tecumseh i got nothing else
to do right i'll [ __ ] read up on that
i'll use it as a reference the next time
i'm in the northwest
territories you guys know who tecumseh
is
oh he kicked your [ __ ] ass about
thinking you know
come up to the elitist um
oh why would you do that uh
because it's fun
anyway hey it's almost the end of the
month an old billy redface
no sticks no cigars in july i smoked no
cigars in february
april and july
we are in the seventh month so i'm still
losing the game
three months to four so
i gotta come away with the victory i
need seven
zero months but even then i mean march
was one cigar
um close but one cigar sorry and
uh may was two cigars so i've been doing
great it wasn't for the month of june
with a big fat ass seven it's like golf
you know i pard
i bogeyed i part i double bogeyed and
then i shot a [ __ ]
seven on the six hole
you know but i calm myself down calm
myself down
all right who gives a [ __ ] it's not like
i'm near the clubhouse and everybody saw
what just happened
now i got a big fat zero i was watching
[ __ ]
uh robert kelly had this video of his
um humidor and all that type of stuff
and i was sitting there saying to myself
don't watch this bill
bill don't watch this you know but i
love bobby so i gotta watch it
right and he also knows a ton of [ __ ]
about cigars and he had a guy that knew
even more than him that [ __ ] works
blah blah blah blah so
he was reviewing this cigar i think i
still have it in my search thing
somewhere
along with hitler smiling
i already lost it now it's probably a
good thing that i lost it
whatever this cigar brand is it means
tattoo in spanish
um i don't know because with a t
this giant [ __ ] like 60 gauge which
is [ __ ]
ridiculously huge cigar and he's
and now because of that i now follow
that company
on uh instagram and i already follow la
aurora and i always see those and i just
sit there and
i stare at the cigar and i make the
picture bigger
and all of that [ __ ] but you know what i
don't i don't [ __ ] with it
i want to wait
can you imagine if i waited till corona
was over to smoke my next cigar i'd be
like the healthiest [ __ ] person ever
unless i got corona um like that guy in
texas got
he was supposed to fly with trump and
then they tested him
you know oh no mass square in texas you
ain't [ __ ] telling us what to do i
don't care how smart you are
you're a doctor you're one of them
liberal doctors
you're just telling me this because
you're trying to muffle my voice so no
one can hear my ideas
um and that is what everybody in texas
sounds like
and what they all think of no that's not
what they sound like just the ones in
austin
um
have i ever told you how annoyed i am
with all these different [ __ ] cities
that have adopted that thing
keep insert city name weird
keep austin weird keep portland weird
keep this place we we're so [ __ ]
creative
man what with your [ __ ] tie-dye
shirts that have been around for 50
[ __ ] years
um anyway
i'm being a little [ __ ] because i got
up [ __ ] too soon what do you want
from me
you know as much as you might not be
enjoying this podcast right now
you now know that there are pictures on
the internet of hitler smiling
how about that um
all right is it time to read the
advertising maybe it is
[Music]
all right and with that energy here we
go i got a new tv show here that's going
to be promoting i'm supposed to promote
here blood
ties blood ties is a premium television
drama
captured in a podcast format
many have described it as secession or
is it succession
or susquehan meets dirty john
dirty john that's i've been watching
this season with amanda pete
and uh christian slater uh
the series follows the richland family's
journey to
unearth the truth and explores the metoo
movement
with their father uh dr richland
wait a minute the series follows the
richland family's journey to unearth the
truth and explore the me too movement
with their father doctor i want to
i want to listen to this right podcast
format being accused of various crimes
the show stats the voice talent of josh
gad
from frozen uh
jillian jacobs from community
dominic monaghan
from lost amy landecker
from transparent and wayne knight from
seinfeld
um our family members are not always who
we think
uh when eleanor and michael spoiler
alert
richard lose their parents unexpectedly
in a small plane crash
they must choose between honoring their
father's legacy as a world renowned
cardiologist and health care magnate
or risk it all to tell the truth in the
newly released second season they must
grapple with the consequences of their
decision
as well as stumbling upon disturbing new
revelations about the family business
well that's right on brand for this
[ __ ] podcast considering i just found
pictures of hitler smiling
i mean which hitler is he
is he that little guy chuckling or is he
a mass murderer in
psycho um cbdmd
everybody cbdmd uh it doesn't matter
if you're a professional athlete a
stay-at-home parent
or you spend eight hours a day in an
uncomfortable office chair
everyone needs support to make it
through the day
um did you just compare sitting in an
office chair
to [ __ ] running a sweep and getting
stuck by ray lewis
okay luckily our friends at cbmd
cbdmd have an amazing do of topical
products that can help you
relax regroup and recharge when life
gets chaotic
uh talking points cbd freeze oh doesn't
that sound wonderful with
menthol is an award-winning product that
offers
instant cooling relief for muscles and
joints in a convenient and easy to use
roller or shareable squeezable tub oh
what am i talking about i have one of
those
i [ __ ] put it on my shoulder it's
tremendous
tremendous i end up i feel like uh my
shoulder rinsed its mouth out with some
scope
um cbd recover combines a cbd with
inflammation fighting compounds like
arnica and vitamin b6 to give you the
support you need when it matters most
and i'll tell you if you're an old
fellow like me
after a workout you got to do it
it is it is life-changing all right
and it's a way you can still stay in
shape you know
keep the guns going and to make it even
easier to try this amazing duo of
topicals and everything else cbdmd
has to offer they offering all my
listeners 20
off your next order at cbdmd.com
charlie bravo deltamikedelta.com
when you use the promo code burr at
checkout once again
that's cbdmd.com promo code burr for 20
off your purchase of superior cbd oil
products
from c b d m
d okay
all right you got your cbd md right
it's one of your most valuable
possessions
where are you gonna put it you're gonna
put it not in your medicine cabinet
you're gonna keep it in
you're simply safe
no it's not a safe it's not a well safe
it's a home security system here's the
thing about home security companies
everybody
most trap you with high prices tricky
contracts
and lousy customer support yeah it's
like you got a cell phone for your house
same [ __ ] goddamn people so while
there are a lot of options out there
there's only one no-brainer it's simply
safe
simply safe's got everything you need to
protect your home with none of the
drawbacks of traditional home security
it's an arsenal of sensors and cameras
to blanket every room
window and door tailored specifically to
your home
professional monitoring keeps watch day
and night ready to send police fire or
medical professionals
oh to send to police fire or medical
professionals
if there's an emergency you can set it
up yourself
in under an hour this is the big part
you can set it up yourself
in under an hour just peel and stick the
sensors exactly where you need them
no technician required and there's no
contract no pushy sales guys no hidden
fees no fear you got some troubled teen
who's sneaking out the window
to go bang her toothless [ __ ] methy
boyfriend
you can keep traps on him right here no
fine print
and all this stats at just fifteen
dollars a month
i'm not the only one who thinks simply
safe is great us
news and world report named it the best
overall
home security of 2020. try simply safe
today at simplysafebird.com
you get free shipping and a free
shipping and a 60-day risk free trial
there's nothing to lose
that's simply safe s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
burr.com
that's it why did i feel it was three
reads oh there was three wreaths the
first one was to promote them
uh a tv show blood ties
i love my daddy don't tell don't tell me
he grabbed some titties he wasn't
supposed to grab
he was just trying to check her heart
rate
he was a cardiologist that is a [ __ ]
crazy thing
because i actually have a confession to
make on the whole me too thing
um i i was a big multi-mario fan
i still am a big multi-mario fan i don't
like what the guy did after
he was uh done cooking but i bought some
of his cookware and i still have
his um i have a multo mario
[ __ ] uh crock pot dutch oven whatever
the [ __ ] you call it
and uh it's got a big m on top of it
for i think it says mm multo mario maybe
just says m on it or maybe it's mb
so it's known as the uh multimario metoo
pot some of the best meals
that i make the short rib recipe
the pot roast i make all of that you
know what i'm gonna do next time i make
a [ __ ] pot roast
oh what are you gonna do bill well first
of all i'm gonna add more salt
because that was the criticism of the
last time you know
um i'm going to try to recreate the
roast beef hash
that uh is at the smith and wilinsky
in uh new york city that they have
friday mornings because
you know traditionally people get paid
thursday so then they'd come to smith
and wilinski they'd have a nice [ __ ]
steak dinner and then they'd saddle up
to the bar and they'd get all [ __ ] up
and the next day you woke jesus christ
what do you have you dehydrated you got
yourself a good old-fashioned hangover
right so they made this roast beef hash
is hangover food and it's was [ __ ]
out of this world so the next time i
make a pot roast
i found a good road i could find a good
recipe for a roast beef hatch
that i'm gonna make and uh what's weird
in my house
is i am the only one who seems to like
midwestern food
um that's where my bloodline is from
and uh so all that meat and potatoes
[ __ ]
i love it i love it and my wife is
50 50 in on it and then my daughter
absolutely [ __ ] hates mashed potatoes
breaks my heart every time she'll be
like dante what's for dinner
and i'll be like something something
something and mashed potatoes and then
she looks at me and she goes
mashed potatoes yuck she says it
with a big smile on her face because she
knows it bugs me
um anyway um
nhl hockey is back which is [ __ ]
amazing and uh
as much as i've i've enjoyed enjoyed
ah most motor sports and uh most sports
that i've watched without crowds i've
actually
really enjoyed it it's i was watching
really enjoying baseball hearing the pop
of the glove the
catcher's mitt and that type of [ __ ] um
i do have to tell you hockey i was
watching the [ __ ]
exhibition toronto maple leafs first the
montreal canadiens
which was the [ __ ] rivalry up until
about 1967 when
for whatever unexplained reason
the maple leaf stopped winning
championships it made no
[ __ ] sense whatsoever
with the canadians their dominance
lasted
for another decade um
where they absolutely destroyed
everybody they won
68 69 71 73
76 77 78 79
that's four five six seven eight they
were like one or two ahead of toronto
in stanley cups in 1967 it was like
lakers and celtics so i should say
celtics lakers right
um and then they just the other one just
stopped winning them
you know which kind of happened with the
celtics we've only won one since 1986
and the lakers have gone on to win in
87.
see if i can do this 2000 2001
2002 um
2009.
something like that i don't know
anyway they just stopped [ __ ] winning
them but anyway so i'm watching this
this is like one of the oldest rivalries
ever
and um you know i think there
there might be some at least on my side
of the puck
there is an unwritten rule that i have
that whoever's playing the [ __ ]
canadians i root for them so i root for
toronto and i want
like if the bruins don't win a cup i
always root for toronto
because toronto i think is still the
closest
although detroit might have almost tied
them oh jesus christ let's look this up
let's get something a better search in
my [ __ ]
computer other than hitler smiling
is that a hashtag is that trending on
twitter um all right
what do we got here uh
most stanley cups
by team
list here we go yep toronto maple leafs
have 13
the red wings have 11 and believe it or
not in fourth place
is the boston bruins with six
that can't be right having the penguins
won six at this point or they won
five i think they won five
um nine more let's see what we got here
nine more rows the blackhawks also have
six
the edmonton oilers have five pittsburgh
penguins have
five i mean those two there are the
modern canadians
in um you know
maple leafs in that that they've won the
most i would say in the modern era
you know and also you got to respect
that with they've they've been doing it
with like
28 to 30 teams as opposed to doing it
predominantly against five other teams
um i don't know and then uh the
islanders have
four the rangers have four the devils
have three
flyers have two colorado has two kings
have two
that's [ __ ] amazing that like
the canadians have 24
24 so let's see here so they won four
five six seven eight yeah so they had 16
and i think in 67 they had 16 and
toronto had 13. they had 15 or 16 but
toronto was in striking distance of them
um and then they just [ __ ]
went off and won eight of the next like
it seemed like the next
i don't know 12 or 13 of them
um and then that was it and then they
won again in 86 with the great patrick
wah
and then one again in 93 one of the most
exciting runs even as a bruins fan i can
admit that they won more goddamn
overtime games than i've ever seen
any team win it was a [ __ ] incredible
playoff
and then the next year you got to see
the rangers with mark messier
you got to see them win it before the
awful new jersey devils and their
boring ass clutching grab all of that
[ __ ] lock
horseshit um
then the red wings they were fun to
watch
the stars i hate that championship
because [ __ ]
the guy was in the crease they called it
the whole [ __ ] year the biggest
goddamn goal
and those poor [ __ ] people out in
buffalo still waiting for a goddamn
championship
up to their [ __ ] eyeballs and wings
that we have all
culturally appropriated to our sports
bars around the [ __ ] country and
those sons of [ __ ] cannot get that
[ __ ] thing overturned
i mean that guy was so obviously in the
crease that is right up there as far as
[ __ ] overs go
with is is right up there with what
happened to the uh
was it the [ __ ] cardinals in 1985
where that guy was out by a
full [ __ ] step
although whitey herzog and those guys
they let it get to him
and they [ __ ] emotionally [ __ ] the
bed and got the living [ __ ] kicked out
of him in game seven i believe that
that's what happened
i'm talking all kinds of [ __ ] here
people i'm talking about sports
i'm talking about little people i'm
talking about the fuhrer with the big
[ __ ] christmas smile on his face
was he a christian i don't know what the
[ __ ] he was
what was his religion people actually
said that he was part jewish
i have no idea i actually said he was
short he was five nine
you know i like i'm five nine and three
quarters he'd have to if he was [ __ ]
telling me you know that i was part of a
mongrel ginger race
and he was fitting to [ __ ] get rid of
me too you know what the greatest thing
about it
is he'd have to look up a little bit
when he said it to me
and i'm gonna take that you know i'm
gonna take that
and carry that with me today um all
right
that is the podcast everybody uh
please send me some uh because i i
literally can't figure out
what the [ __ ] happened in the war of
1812. i definitely feel like my country
is
is glossing over a lot of [ __ ]
um as far as how we got into it it seems
you know britain was being [ __ ] but you
know they had the best navy back then so
that's what you do i mean we turned
around and did the same [ __ ] thing
when russia fell
went through their [ __ ] then we were
the big [ __ ] on the block and look what
the [ __ ] we did we
everybody abuses their par everybody in
their own way has their little multo
mario dutch oven somewhere in their
[ __ ] kitchen historically speaking
right so uh
i think part of it might be
that because britain was so busy
fighting
with the little fella there over in
france you know
uh it'd be funny if you know part of him
losing
was they force-fed him like they do with
those [ __ ]
the foie gras they foie guatem right
um they he they were so busy dealing
with napoleon
that we thought that we had an
opportunity to expand west and actually
go
up into uh canada
and try and kick them out of this face
of the [ __ ]
off the face of this part of the globe
that's one of those expressions i just
combined off the face of the earth
to then make it part of my it just you
really just saw how [ __ ] dumb i am
and how much you just wasted the last
38 minutes 30 seconds of your life
um anyways that is the podcast
all right now there's gonna be some
music um
curated by the wonderful and always
brilliant andrew themless
um and then we're gonna have a bonus
episode
another half hour from a thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcasts from i don't know
a number of years ago a greatest hits if
you will a pre-covered
back in a simpler time you know
when there was no covid and you could
sexually abuse
anybody you wanted in the office
pre me too pre hitler smiling
i don't know when i did it all right go
[ __ ] yourselves i'll have a great
weekend you [ __ ]
and i'll i'll talk to you on monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast from
monday
july 30th 2012
2012 12 years past the year of our lord
the year 2000 remember that and all the
computers were going to crash and
everyone was going to run around with
their hair
on fire and what happened
nothing oh my god here comes an asteroid
where yeah
i missed us how many [ __ ] times are
they gonna cry wolf
how many times are they gonna say that
everything's gonna [ __ ] end
and it never does i wanna know
i wanna know they call me
the big pretender
songs in my head today i don't know why
maybe it's because you don't like
yourself bill
and you're sick of the lies
maybe it is i don't know what all i know
is i took my dog out for a walk
she did a four which is number two twice
first one was solid second one started
to come out like it was going to be and
then all something
right then what do i do i do you know
what i do i do my best
i do my best to be a responsible
neighbor you know i saw three people in
my neighborhood just sitting in a car
and i just immediately assumed that they
were pieces of [ __ ]
they had tattoos they were smoking
cigarettes they just look like scumbags
and i was sitting there going well
they're kind of sort of white so that's
not racist is it
but they're a real specific kind of
white like their nationality they were
of whatever the [ __ ] they were and i'll
tell you right now i didn't like them
all right and my inner old man was
starting to come out like girl
get out of here they gotta ruin
the neighborhood it's weird when you buy
a house you just
suddenly become really conservative
before when i rented i didn't give a
[ __ ] if there was a homeless guy
jerking off in the street i thought it
was funny look at that guy right outside
my window who needs cable when that
guy's sitting there rubbing one out ah
look at the lady running
it was great but once you buy you every
[ __ ] little thing
ah there's a pothole down the street it
needs to be covered
i did the other day that's how old i am
i called
for the first time in my life do you
have man can we help you please
now listen here there's that old guy
you know old people [ __ ] oh people
[ __ ] like that you already heard the
point nine times you know
welcome to 3-1-1 what can we help you
with this pothole
is still not covered i don't know which
one you're talking about
crazy old man crazy freckly old man bill
um yeah so i'm doing the podcast late
today
and uh you know i'm doing it late today
because i recorded one and it wasn't
funny
and i have a certain level of quality
control i had to go get some nourishment
and at the end of the day i'll do this
thing whenever the [ __ ] i damn well
please
all right so all you twitter [ __ ] you
tcs out there if you want to keep
[ __ ] writing to me and [ __ ] moaning
and complaining just know this i don't
give a [ __ ]
you know i know why you keep bitching at
me because there's this new culture now
where you have to apologize for nothing
is that what you're waiting for me to do
do you want me to go on on twitter and
issue an apology i find it offensive
that he calls
it the monday morning podcast and when
he records it it's his monday morning
and not
mine i feel it's false go [ __ ] yourself
that's what this week was this was a
week of watching people that i'm
huge fans of having to apologize or semi
apologize or finesse
for for nothing absolutely nothing fred
willard
who doesn't like fred willard you know
he allegedly rubbed one out or something
touched himself in a
lewd way lewd's such a great word isn't
it that really just
sounds like what the [ __ ] it is lewd
you know crude anything ood
is not good right
zooed is there another word lewd crude
mood that mood could be uh shut up bill
what are you trying to do some [ __ ]
seinfeld bit here why
because everything that goes
um yeah lewd lou just sounds like you're
touching your
[ __ ] balls doesn't it yeah a lewd act
that should like come with that sound
effect your honor the uh suspect is
being charged with two counts of a lewd
act
right and you gotta like act it out as
you say it
no well you would in my court um
in my fantasy court that i have um yeah
fred willard
allegedly touched himself while watching
a porno
and he has to [ __ ] issue some sort of
state for what
for you know first of all i don't
understand what
why are you apologizing to me or why are
you trying to clear the air with me i
don't care what you do
just make a good movie and i'll go see
it i don't care what you're doing
like oh if you're out murdering people
and touching kids yeah i have a problem
but if you're rubbing one out i don't
give a [ __ ]
is it or is it not a good movie fred
willard if it is i will go see it
regardless
of how you empty your balls i don't care
the only reason why i needed to hear him
issue a statement would be
he should only issued a statement to the
person who owned the me
the movie theater the guy whose job it
is to mop up after the shows
and possibly the person that was sitting
in front
in front of him and that only is if when
fred
climaxes he rises to his feet
other than that what do you why i don't
need to know about it i don't give a
[ __ ]
i don't care what anybody does if you're
not hurting somebody
john travolta is getting a massage he
goes hey you want to rub one out there
male masseuse and the guy goes no i
don't
and then i don't give a [ __ ] and then
what i'm not gonna see his next movie if
it's good i'm gonna go see it i don't
care what that guy does
it's none of my business and i don't
think any of that [ __ ] is embarrassing
or i don't think there's any shame you
know it's not our fault
our balls fill up and we got to get rid
of it
you know and there's a bunch of
different ways to do it and if you're
not hurting anybody i don't see what the
problem is
you know i don't get why why you're
apologizing i mean you jerked off to
allegedly jerked off to a porno i mean
what are you gonna do next
somebody's gotta apologize for playing
catch with a baseball i mean that's what
that's what it's there for i mean they
make pornos so you jerk off to them
all right if you don't want somebody to
jerk off and you [ __ ] allegedly jerk
off in your movie theater don't [ __ ]
show pornos
why don't you show spider-man okay
there you go there you go if he was
jerking off while watching spider-man
jesus christ fred there's kids there you
know
and even then if he wasn't looking at
any of them if he just was truly turned
on by spider-man or the the chick
who was dating peter parker that that's
to me that's his own [ __ ] issue
you're good with me fred willard i'm
gonna go see your next movie whether i
think it looks good or not what do you
think about that and
a little show of solidarity
i'm sick of [ __ ] this this whole new
uh
this new what do they call this new
climate now this new
uh uh petri dish what the [ __ ] is it
this new
atmosphere hey you know i went to one of
those chemical bars the other night
wasn't drinking and i went there and it
was one of those things where they
[ __ ] you know
it's like a chemistry thing this guy's
got a paintbrush out he's painting the
inside of a glass
then he lights something on fire blows
it out puts the smoke
into the glass and then pours the drink
in and everybody then drinks it is like
oh my god this is the most amazing thing
i don't buy it i couldn't taste i mean
my
sense of taste and smell is kind of bad
but i to me it just seemed like that
dude on green acres
you know when he would come up with some
hunk of [ __ ] like just a rusted out
radiator and be like this is a genuine
uh bassoon from rio i mean just he would
just make up [ __ ]
this guy basically was trying to say
that he takes an apple
and he sucks the atmosphere out of it
that he literally said that in like
colorado or something i i don't know
what the [ __ ] he was talking about
and he tells you this [ __ ] story that
is
so heavy on the chemistry you can't help
but feel like a [ __ ] idiot
so by the time he dips the straw in it
and gives you a chance to taste it it's
like that moment when you're in a fancy
restaurant
and somebody gives you pours a glass of
wine
and it's that that you know as you're
swirling it around acting like you can
taste the difference between a 90
and a [ __ ] four dollar bottle of wine
i can't i have never
drank wine and been like yeah you know
no
no it's [ __ ] wine it tastes like wine
like i i don't have that
sophisticated level of pal so by the
time this guy got done
explaining sucking the atmosphere out of
an apple it's like at this point
if it's almost like if you say it tastes
like a goddamn
you know what it tasted like it tasted
like uh
you know like homemade popsicles you
know awful or or when you have a
popsicle
and it kind of melted a little bit and
there's that the gooey [ __ ]
is on the inside of the wrapper and for
some reason you you you lick the rapper
just how [ __ ] gross
i mean it tasted like that level is
sweet and everybody was just taking the
straws just taking that they were like
oh my god
and i was like either i'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] or this is like
the emperor's new clothes because uh
this [ __ ] just just it tastes like a
popsicle
um was that story worth telling i don't
know looking back
maybe not but looking forward
um a buddy of mine stand-up comedian was
involved in a
scandal air quotes you know what he was
doing
he was in a comedy club trying out new
jokes
can you believe that what the [ __ ] was
he thinking
people does anybody out there understand
that you have no right to get offended
when you when you
as a as a an adult make the free choice
to go into a comedy club
all right you don't have a right to be
offended
you don't you don't
all right you just the second you walk
in there everything is [ __ ] free game
that's what it is all right that's
it's not like you hired a comedian to do
a private party
and you gave him a list of [ __ ] of
subjects that you wanted him to stay
away from him or her
and that comedian agreed to it now if
that's the case you're paying him and
said hey
don't bring up uh [ __ ] cheese whiz
and the person does a bit on and agrees
to not do it and then goes up there and
does that exact thing then yeah not only
do they owe you an apology you shouldn't
even [ __ ] pay them because they they
voided out the contract
but in a comedy club you didn't hire
those comedians you decided to go down
there and watch comedians
try out material give you their best
[ __ ] give
something that kind of works throw some
[ __ ] against the wall that's our house
that's our dojo you're not entitled to a
[ __ ] apology
um i thought that was the most half the
people bitching
about that dang cook joke it's like they
don't even get the joke
the joke was not making fun of the
victims in colorado it was using that as
as a as a reference he was talking about
how bad he thought the new batman movie
was
so right out of the gate half the people
didn't even get what the [ __ ] joke
was about
and then secondly dane didn't film
himself
and then upload that onto the internet
somebody in the crowd did
right so why does he have to apologize
he told that joke in la
and they tell you at the beginning of
the show
do not videotape the comedians please do
not videotape the comedians and the
person videotapes them
and by the way i heard the crowd laugh
jokes sounded like it did all right
wasn't a complete joke it's just you
know something he's working on
and some of the best material comes out
of that material so he has to basically
apologize
for building a new hour of material
you know i don't get that you don't like
and i don't think the comedian should
apologize
i think it's absolute [ __ ] and um
look there's all different kinds of
comedy there's dark comedy
there's there's absurd there's blue
there's squeaky clean
and it's like music there's all
different kinds of music go gravitate
towards the [ __ ] that you like
but like you know if some [ __ ] in the
crowd films a comedian in a comedy club
our house our dojo and puts it up there
if you got a [ __ ] problem
with uh it being there talk to the
person who videotaped it because i think
that's the only person that needed to
apologize
all right he should apologize for dane
for taking taping his act
and then he should apologize to anybody
uh
you know i guess who who [ __ ] saw
this
new joke that dane didn't put on a
special or do
on [ __ ] letterman it's the stupidest
[ __ ] thing on the planet
go [ __ ] yourself and you know what kills
me is when you apologize you're actually
i
i feel like that's an admission then
you're saying the other person was right
like yeah i meant that in a malicious
way
you know like what kind of a [ __ ]
watched that joke and actually thought
that dane
was actually supporting what that psycho
did in colorado
you know what i mean who who is that
[ __ ] stupid
you know i don't know and like i said at
the end of the day
he just told the joke in the comedy club
and the crowd left
that's what kills me on all of these the
crowd [ __ ]
laughs i wrote on twitter i'm going to
quote myself here
to have to have and just just have a new
level of arrogance on this podcast
you know after the last one was it tosh
i think was the last one
is the philosophical question is if a
comedian tells a joke in a comedy club
and the whole crowd
laughs except for one person
is it really a national news story
you know because that's another thing
too is i feel like that's just like
it's like a good way to kill five
minutes on a newscast
where you can just say that there's
outrage where there was no outrage there
was no outrage
there wasn't if there was like truly
outraged
you were heard it after he told the joke
you would have heard people yelling out
groans moans
you would have heard that you didn't you
heard a the joke got
a decent laugh that was it
and then he moved on to the next one
it's
i mean is that was that what doing
stand-ups gonna be now you're gonna have
to sit there and be like i'd like to
apologize to anybody
who is lactose intolerant i uh
should have chosen my words more
carefully go [ __ ] yourself
right am i out of my mind
i i don't know
it's a whole new world whole new world
of [ __ ] snitches
just out there just trying to get people
in trouble
all right well here's something for you
evoice everybody
would you like to have a would you like
to have your cell phone ring
but have people not know what your real
number is
you know wouldn't you like to get like
have a cell phone right and only your
friends and family knew the real number
to it
and then you could come up with these
virtual phone numbers that people could
dial that but weren't really your phone
number
but your cell phone would still ring
would you be into that would you be into
a service like evoice that will allow
you to do that
and off these these virtual phone
numbers you could actually
uh you could do conference calling on
your own new business
and on the conference call a feature we
could have actually up to 95 people for
each extension
it's incredible it's basically it's a
business phone number that will
that will ring on your cell phone okay
without anybody knowing your personal
one which gives you the option
of knowing whether it's a business one
or a personal one and not answering it
and whatever it's absolutely perfect
it's an amazing thing
they offer an entire service where you
can uh
toll-free local managing of outgoing
calls this is all all the uh
this is all the the the what are the
options i can't even think this week
uh mobility all calls forwarded to a
number
slash people don't have to know your uh
your personal phone number
virtual number so long as you have a
real number you can give out
fake numbers but it rings on your own
number and
if you don't pick up on your business uh
your your new virtual
um phone number they actually have
professional accents
uh professional uh voice actors
to give you any any sort of like like an
outgoing message like if you want to
give the illusion
that your business is bigger than it is
you have a bunch of employees
one of the options that they have is
that you can actually have like i
personally i would pick some sexy
female voice with like a british accent
just gives your business credibility
you know they'll send you emails with
the text transcription of the voicemail
um or not the option is totally yours
uh it's a great way to basically
have all these different business lines
without having to drill a bunch of holes
in the wall in your house
you know you got hello welcome to uh
widget widgets r us or whatever i'm
doing a bad accent you know what i'm
saying you can start the whole freaking
thing so it's email uh e-voice
check it out today do i have a website
here where the hell is it
uh hang on one second let me get this
website
yeah it's evoiced.com there you go bill
you're genius
um once again evoice is your mobile
phone at work it's perfect for business
uh business person on the move uh like
myself i'm actually gonna get one of
these phone numbers just because when i
travel from club to club and all these
uh
different radio stations like my my
phone number gets out there and
and i i get weird phone calls sometimes
you know
i rented a car in chicago at like avis
like three months ago
and then out of nowhere i got it i had
to write down my my [ __ ] cell phone
number and uh the guy worked at avis
called me up
oh actually sent me a text hey saw your
stand up the other day really funny
i'm the guy who rented you the car at
avis which is beyond creepy and i'm a
dude so i can only imagine how that
would make a female so it gives you the
great
like uh privacy options
while you still exist in the business
world um features evoice offers includes
call forwarding call routing
toll-free 800 numbers auto attendant
um advanced voicemail voicemail to text
or voicemail to email however the hell
you want to do it
uh click on the evoice banner on
billboard.com on the podcast page or go
to www.evoice.com
to get your exclusive six-month free
trial
six-month free trial evil yeah e-voice
your mobile phone at work
um that's one of those ideas where i'm
just like that right there is why i'm
not a billionaire
because i just look at that like that
idea was just out there
and uh i just did nothing
why didn't i jump on that like youtube
that's one of those ideas
um anyways uh another thing real real
quick here we got legalzoom
and this is for uh so evoice there's
your business phone number now if you
actually want to get incorporated
these two right here e-voice and
legalzoom if you're sitting in a cubicle
right now and you want to somehow get
out if you have a business idea
or an invention or anything these two
these two companies will get
will will somehow get you out of that
god damn cubicle all right here we go
legal zoom um you've probably heard
about legalzoom.com uh but now
i'm telling you about it so you gotta
check them out these guys are uh
these guys are great and i wish i knew
about them when i was gonna get
incorporated uh if you've been waiting
for the perfect time to start your dream
business it's right now
incorporate your business or form an llc
at legalzoomdark.com
starting at just 99 bucks i paid like
1500.
i had an accountant and a lawyer and all
that crap it cost me 1500 bucks these
guys start off
at 99 bucks and then a whole nother
level if you have a family
and you want to protect them uh guess
what you can protect your family
and assist with the legals and assets
but the legal zoom will
for just 69 bucks all right in the past
twelve years over two million americans
have used legalzoom
for llc's wills trusts trademarks and
more they've saved hundreds even
thousands of dollars versus going to a
traditional lawyer
legalzooms online process guides guide
you step by step
you get total customer support it
couldn't be much easier i know what a
lot of you are thinking well there's all
that legal mumbo jumbo
what if i fill it out wrong don't worry
about it they even have attorneys that
can help you out
if you need uh if you need it as you're
working through all the legal
legalities of it um so anyway start your
business and protect your family today
at legalzoom.com
you also get a special discount from
listening to this podcast make sure you
enter bur
b-u-r-r and the referral box at checkout
for more savings legalzoom is not a law
firm and self-help services
are provided at your direction
there you go all right so there's that
back to the podcast
did i read that correctly do i have to
apologize to anybody
you know who do i have to apologize for
that the uh
reading out loud anonymous
foundation whatever the [ __ ] it is have
you noticed that they only go after they
only try to make really successful
people apologize
because god knows i've said enough [ __ ]
on this podcast haven't i that at some
point shouldn't i have to issue an
apology
you know i don't that's why i like i
like my life
is no one's dependent on me i go out i
do stand up
no biggie right it's just me i do this
podcast
it's just me if i [ __ ] this up i just
[ __ ] myself over
but either way you can't stop me from
doing either one of these
you know maybe you can affect the amount
of listeners i have amount of people
come out to my shows but
i'm not motivated by money you know as
you can tell by my wardrobe
my motivation is i don't ever want to
have somebody telling me what i have to
do
you know hey get over there and pick up
that but you go [ __ ] pick it up you
[ __ ]
you know i always hated that i don't
like having a boss
so that was my dream in life not having
a boss and i don't so
you can do it yourself get your [ __ ]
ass out of your cubicle
all right get yourself a a a virtual
phone number at e-voice
and get yourself incorporated or
trademark your invention
at legalzoom.com right there i gave you
the tools
you know oh shut up bill all right i'll
shut up
um oh by the way speaking of dane cook
let's talk about some positive
dang cook news um dane sent me an email
all right i'm in his circle not bragging
he mentioned that he was going to be at
the hollywood bowl performing
in the musical the producers and he said
come on down if you want to
so i was in that dilemma where i love
dane but i i'm not a fan of musicals
um i'm just not a fan of them
and that goes by just you know you know
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] as i went and i
saw one and i actually enjoyed it
but that's just one of those guy things
you can't say that you're a fan of a
musical
you know so i went down they're like all
right i got to support dance i'm going
to go down thing it was [ __ ]
hilarious
it was at the hollywood bowl and uh
unbelievable performances and i'm gonna
tell you something right now dane
absolutely [ __ ] killed it i wish i
had near down here because i'm friends
you know you're thinking oh you're
friends with them so you're just gonna
say that no he [ __ ] killed it
and i was so proud of him and i was
sitting there watching it
remembering all these hell gigs we did
like 20 years ago
at like [ __ ] this pub
kelly's was the first time i think i saw
dane or maybe at this comedy club
stitches i mean
half the gigs i like the first 200 gigs
i did
half of them were done in places where
it wasn't a comedy club and most of the
crowd didn't even know that there was
going to be a show
and we'd always be in the corner i
remember to be me
dane aldel benny bobby kelly patrice
o'neill
all the guys i started we'd just be
huddling over in the corner just going
oh this is going to suck this is going
to eat a bag of dicks that was like one
of the first comedy expressions i
learned
this is going to suck a big bag of
[ __ ] elk dick
and you would just sit there and watch
your friend go up there
and just absolutely just humiliation
just standing there
trying to make people laugh who aren't
listening and don't want a [ __ ] show
and just taking those [ __ ] lumps
and i remember dame would just was
always would go
full out totally commit and when i was
watching him in that
show last night i was seeing all these
little
little subtle things that i used to see
him do in all his hell rooms and
it was [ __ ] great and i said what's
up to him in the end and when i walked
out
it was hilarious was uh one of the leads
in it is that redheaded dude with the
with the beard
on modern family the guy was hilarious
he was he was great in this musical too
and uh when i walked out was [ __ ]
hilarious i see this guy look kind of
tilts his head to the side he got
excited looking at me as i'm walking out
and then his face dropped and i was like
you know my ego i'm thinking oh he
recognizes me as a comedian and
uh i can't confirm this but i think he
thought i was that dude
from a distance he thought i was that
guy on modern family
and then when he saw me in my hairline
he's like oh that's that's not him
that's just some jackass with a beard um
oh wasn't that sad
hey i got a drum question for you all uh
for the drummers any drummers who listen
to this
um i i can't decide on this one that
song
by van halen uh mean streets
does alex play that the hi-hat does he
play it with two hands or with one
i saw him live in concert he played it
with two and then i watched a video the
other day and he played it with one
uh but he wasn't playing straight
sixteenths but when i listen to it on
the album it sounds like it's straight
sixteenths
can somebody please help me with that
because i'm working getting back to
the push pull thing with the stick
trying to get it up to speed
and how do you do that i listen to lenny
kravitz uh it ain't over till it's over
and then i listen to what's his face uh
uh
bill withers use me and i just
keep i play up to tempo with each hand
and each day i can play a little bit
longer but i pay attention to the fact i
don't want my forearms burning because
if they are then i'm not doing it right
you know for those who aren't drummers
one of the things your problem you have
is
uh you know if you have great technique
you can effortlessly play the drums and
you don't have to deal with carpal
tunnel or any [ __ ]
injuries or any of that [ __ ] so sorry
that was my own little thing and
speaking of that i want to start i want
to start making some drum covers
and upload them onto youtube anonymously
you guys will never find them so good
luck to you but i i'm using that imovie
and i don't i obviously you know can
film myself and upload myself but i
don't know how to
how do you drop the music in you know
what i mean
so you hear my drums playing you know
it's like i shoot the video and all you
hear is me playing the drums
to whatever song right and then what i
want to do is drop in the audio of the
song
and like obviously have it in sync to me
playing the drums
because i just want to see what kind of
reviews i'm going to get because if i
put it up there and it's me first of all
it's going to look cheesy and then
second of all it's gonna be i don't know
i want people looking at i want people
watching it like this guy actually wants
to try and make it as a drummer because
i want honest
criticism and then i i'm not gonna tell
you where they are
on youtube but i will read you the worst
comments how about that is that fair
that'll be good for some comedy all
right okay here we go response to penn
state
should keep their wins last week i
talked about uh
you know obviously i agreed with every
every punishment that came down on penn
state except for the
uh i just thought them losing their
victories i just felt like that punished
the players
and the fans and the fans and the
players were 100 percent
innocent and these guys whose nfl dreams
died because they blew out their knee in
a game that they won and now you're
going to take that away from them and i
just feel like uh
it just seemed like it went above and
beyond so this guy says bill in response
to your
your view that penn state shouldn't have
to forfeit the wins
should germany have been allowed to keep
the countries they conquered in world
war
ii no i like when people ask me a
question
like and i think that they want my
opinion but they just answer it
themselves so he says no
when we kicked their [ __ ] asses we
took away their land
took away their army and placed
sanctions on them we didn't say hey
hitler's dead so why should we punish
the rest of you germans
we made a [ __ ] example out of them
and we need to do to do the same thing
to penn state
not all the germans were nazis not all
the players did anything wrong
did anything wrong dude none of the
players did anything wrong
what [ __ ] what internet do you have
what what
tv shows are you watching um if they
have a problem
go immigrate to another university where
wins
count enough with the poor me [ __ ]
you're supreme holier than now ruler
[ __ ] up big time
[ __ ] him and all you queer lions so
there you go you know what sir you were
starting to make a point there and then
in the end
you you end up you know that that's like
a typical
internet point you start to make a point
and then you either say something racist
or homophobic in the end uh first of all
i
i disagree with that analogy
um because that analogy you're
suggesting
that the penn state players were joe
paterno's army
and that they were in the know and joe
paterno was hitler
and the people in the army were they
knew what the [ __ ] he was doing and they
helped him
they helped him do it which they didn't
they didn't they were just playing
football games
all right and uh
should germany have been allowed to keep
the countries they conquered in world
war
ii well a war is like a game dude that's
a game
all right and they won the first half
and they lost the game so no they
shouldn't be
but uh they did conquer france
and that is in their history books they
fought france in world war
ii and they beat them that victory
counts
they conquered poland they conquered the
[ __ ]
netherlands they lost in england
they lost to the russians and they lost
to us
so right there off the top of my head
they were three and three they conquered
uh
norway with the help of sweden
right all all those wins and losses
count sir so i don't know what you're
saying like that point doesn't make any
sense and the fact in the end you see
you're all uh all you know [ __ ] him and
your queer lions
that basically sounds to me like you're
a fan of a team in the big ten
or maybe you like one of them southern
coaches that had you know more wins than
joe pass so uh
i agree to disagree sir and
um you lose points on your your hacky
example of
germany and the nazis it always comes
down to that
no matter what you do i pick up my dog
[ __ ] and i throw in somebody else's
trash can and they go
sir could you please can't you dad it's
trash you worried that i'm gonna
make you trash think you know
and then they'll say something well did
hitler that's like when hitler
it isn't it isn't like one hitler it
isn't
it isn't okay you should have gone like
john wayne gacy there that's what i
would have gone
anyways all right female roommate howdy
bill
uh you said howdy so i'm reading all
this in a southern accent i could use
some advice
uh i'm a 27 year old guy living in an
apartment and
with a 19 year old girl really she just
moved in a couple weeks ago
a couple months ago uh we've been
getting along great but over the past
few weeks
she's mentioned her sex life a couple of
different times
mentioned how she loves to give head yes
could it be the most perfect room made
in the world
um you're the reason that god made a
[ __ ]
all right so she likes sucking dick okay
i see nothing but sunshine so far
where where's the rain coming here we
going just the other day she mentioned
out of the blue
that she posed for some nude pictures
uh-oh
and she has no problem with nudity all
right that's a major caution flag there
anybody who takes nude photos or is in
the
uh the porn industry yeah you got to
watch out there that's a ticking time
bomb
oh geez what happened was it your uncle
was it the guy down the street
who was it uh she seems to basically say
everything she thinks
uh oh she basically said seems to say
everything that she thinks will get a
rise out of me
rise you get it that's what he said he
put that in parentheses all right here
we go at first i didn't know how to
approach the situation so i just ignored
her when she tried to steer the
conversation towards sex
but she seemed to do this repeatedly and
i had enough with it
and i came on to her and told her that i
wanted to see the pictures and then
joked with her
that it was for artistic reasons um
she seemed shocked that i'd asked such a
question oh here she goes going to yank
the rug out
and she joked with me and called me a
creeper
she seemed to flaunt her sexuality in
front of me and say how open she is with
everything but the second i made a move
she made me feel like a creep there you
go you got one of those sir
you got one of those oh gee oh geez
this is the this is like she's uh an
olympic level uh
uh uh what do you call dick tease and i
say olympic level because she's actually
dabbled in the porn industry with the
nude photos
um i either want to bang this girl or
get her to quit throwing her sexual
suggestive topics at me
and quit using me as an emotional tampon
help me out bill
go [ __ ] yourself i would say exactly
what you just said
not the banging part just say listen um
just you know you know what you do you
just go i would just go [ __ ]
don't curse don't say anything [ __ ] up
just straight out say it just say listen
ever since you've been here you have
been just openly talking about sex
you talk about how you enjoy giving oral
sex you mentioned that you have nude
photos you don't have a problem with
nudity you're constantly bringing up sex
okay and the other day you know
no i can't go that way because then
she'd be like well because you came off
like a creep
just tell her look don't don't bring up
sex anymore
can you just don't don't bring up sex
anymore uh
and just when she says well i just say
because i'm not comfortable with you
talking about it
all right i would just like to have a
roommate to roommate relationship
you know i'm not trying to be a jerk
here just please don't talk about sex
anymore and that would be perfect
because then you will totally like take
away all of her powers you just took the
rope away from wonder woman
right there you know and once you take a
rope off she can't find her jet
isn't that how it worked come on nerds
any nerds listening to this
actually that's not true she could see
her invisible jet
that was one of the dumbest you know
that was such like a chauvinistic
thing that they gave her wasn't it an
invisible jet superman can fly by
himself
doesn't even need doesn't even need a
[ __ ]
plane wonder woman can't fly she needs a
jet just like the rest of ours but to
make it interesting they make it
invisible
now at any point did they say that
wonder woman invented the invisible jet
you know she didn't she didn't she's too
busy
[ __ ] going to the gym you know
keeping her stomach
flat and [ __ ] around with that rope
so that's all she really is she's just
kind of like this uh
well i guess she can block bullets with
her wristbands
so that's unbelievably like reptilian
quickness so i'll give her that but
other than that you know if she wants to
go to california she's got to get on a
plane just like the rest of us
and she's got to fly herself out which i
guess is kind of cool
i don't know how hot was [ __ ] was i
was gonna say linda blair
was linda evans the [ __ ] was her name
claire what was the name of the woman
who played uh wonder woman
in in the late 70s oh did i love her
i've loved
every [ __ ] that's back before there
was like 9 000 channels so every woman
on television back then you know if they
were playing a sexy role it wasn't they
weren't outside the box no pun intended
they were just [ __ ] straight up
they were at 10. she was hot all three
charlie's angels they were all hot
jamie summers the bionic woman she was
[ __ ] hot
um three's company
i thought they were both hot i liked
them all alice was hot
vera was hot in a weird way you could
keep flow there'd be one every once in a
while but they were all they were all
like they were hot gloria
you know if you get past her voice she
was a [ __ ] hottie
that'd have been somebody ugly
it really wasn't marsha was hot jammed
by the end of it she came into her own
yeah just a bunch of hotties
hotties they weren't hoary though they
didn't have [ __ ] back then
you know did they i don't know all right
let's plow ahead here
depressed dude a billy [ __ ]
exclamation point i've been listening
i've been listening to your podcast for
years
your deranged psychopathic perspective
reminds me
i'm not the only one
shaking ladders i don't know what that
means is this guy from boston
i've been listening to the broadcast for
years your deranged psychopathic
perspective reminds me i'm not the only
one shaking ladders kid
that still doesn't sound even if the
accent shaken
ladders i don't know what that means
anyways i got a problem you know i was
in boston all last week so the
bass pop the boston accent kind of came
back the old uh you know i got a problem
says get a job and get a jewel up
dude it needs to get a job and for those
of you working on your boston accents
j-o-b just say like jaw like i'm to
punch you in the jaw
and then be job you got to get a [ __ ]
job
you know what kills me right now is like
[ __ ] 200 you right now just muttering
to yourself getting a [ __ ] jewel up
in your cubicle um
freaking out your co-workers just
mumbling get a [ __ ] job
you [ __ ] [ __ ] sucker um i got a
problem for years now i've been
trapped in my kfc and wet wipes
okay that's disgusting i used to be a
bodybuilder
an actor and a comedian with [ __ ]
prospects right in front of me
but then adulthood raped me in the eyes
oh jesus could you be more dramatic
this sounds like that [ __ ] chick from
uh
sex in the city uh crazy broad
broke my hat i had this is the guy again
crazy broad broke my heart i had to cut
away
old friends and family shutting me out
of their
smiles all right dude this is like
getting creepier with each sentence if
you don't bring this around in like two
sentences i'm gonna abandon this
i had to cut away from old friends and
family shutting me out of their smiles
dude what did you do that your friends
and family decided they didn't want to
be around you
uh anyways i don't feel sorry for myself
or want any pity
uh i just you're not gonna get any so
good i'm glad you don't he goes i just
want to know
how to get out of this never-ending
routine of demise
well first of all i would stop using
those goth death metal words
you know demise what else you got in
here
adult raped me in the eyes are you this
is like song lyrics
you know depressed dude what would be
the name of this trapped
by kfc and wet wipes right
that sounds like i can't sing like that
damn right
in the eyes this routine of demise
all these [ __ ] kids getting like whip
[ __ ] whiplash
um i work too much in a job that was
supposed to pay for
my comedy career when i don't work i
i was supposed to pay for my comedy
career when i when i don't work uh
i sleep or or when i don't work i sleep
or watch endless dvds i'm 24 years old
uh what the [ __ ] this reads like you're
56 dude
he goes i'm tired all the time from all
the hating of the world and my body just
won't listen to this screaming
frustration in my
soul dude you listen to like
you listen to progressive metal i'm
guessing by the words you use here
uh either you play dungeons and dragons
i'm really not helping your depression
by [ __ ] on you through all of this
um don't worry i'm going to give you
some sunshine here in the end here so
it's
i sometimes get a spark of motivation to
get back in shape
and just and start writing script but it
only lasts for a day or two
at the most yeah exactly
and then and then the work comes and you
have to keep going and that's what
separates the people in life
who [ __ ] work and and make it and
those who don't
you know everything's fun for a couple
of [ __ ] days i'm gonna get shredded
i'm gonna join a boxing gym i'm gonna
look like i'm gonna fight in a title
fight you go down there you skip rope
i'm gonna get abs you're doing all the
[ __ ] [ __ ] in two days in you know
after two days
you you get tired all right and that's
where you need the discipline to get up
and go over there even though you don't
want to
you know people who've written
oscar-winning scripts i bet they don't
like [ __ ] doing it
on on a certain level but they keep
going so
i would just tell you to keep [ __ ]
going anyways let me read the rest of
this
overly dramatic [ __ ] i've lost all faith
in the world have nothing to fight for
anymore
i respect your go [ __ ] yourself attitude
and want and want to know what you did
to finally pick yourself up from your
dark
inflicted depression uh sorry it's not
the funniest emails but i could really
do with you i know dude i'm [ __ ] with
you i know you're going through some
[ __ ] so
here we go gonna help you out here uh
first thing i would do get rid of the
kfc and wet wipes
all right if you're already kind of a
depressed dude if you eat bad food
that's just gonna add
because i i'm just speaking personally
once again not a licensed guy here in
case you throw yourself off the [ __ ]
roof all right
um yeah number one
this is what i do go go out and get
something healthy to eat
you know drink some water okay get eight
hours sleep wake up and eat something
healthy
then go to the grocery store when you're
full and go buy a bunch of healthy [ __ ]
okay chop up the veggies chop up the
lettuce get a [ __ ] salad already made
in there so you don't have to think
about it
all right cook up some [ __ ] chicken
chop that [ __ ] up make some chicken
salad
you got that in there too get yourself
some [ __ ] lunch meat
and get yourself some real bread from a
[ __ ] bakery start with that [ __ ]
you start eating right and then just
start working out you're automatically
going to feel good about yourself
and [ __ ] stick with that as far as
that other [ __ ] goes dude you're 24
years old
all right i started comedy when i was
24. you sound like you've already been
doing it and quit
so you're ahead of where where i was at
at your age
so there's no reason to be depressed all
right um
this is how i got beyond my depression
was
i just started observing it
i looked at it as a spectator rather
than feeling a thought and just
accepting it and then being dragged to
the bottom of the [ __ ] ocean with it
i just started to pay attention i just
sat there and listened to what my brain
was telling me
it was a bunch of negative oh my god i'm
going to fail i have to go back moving
with my parents and they're going to die
i'm not going to be able to afford to
pay for the house and then i'm going to
be homeless and then i'm just going to
die
and uh you know nothing's ever going to
work out for me you know
those were the thoughts i was having so
i just sat back and observed them and i
just started
going i i don't want to think that i
want to think that and i would just
as i felt them coming i would just
replace it with like a positive thought
i know this is really corny and simple
but i kind of started doing that
and the more i did that because it
didn't quite work
it actually didn't work in the beginning
at all but like i just kept doing it
more and more and then i just became
conscious of when my brain was going in
that direction
and um working out helps me
eating right helps me going down to a
comedy club telling jokes
helps me out playing drums wrestling
with my dog
you know taking nia out to dinner just
go do something
like it's just a choice
you know july 30th it's only gonna
happen once am i gonna [ __ ]
be a miserable [ __ ] on this or i said
july 30th 2012 is only gonna happen once
it's just it's just a [ __ ] choice
dude so
you know if what you're dealing with is
clinical then it's obviously way beyond
me so i don't need you know and then i
want to [ __ ] apologize like fred
willard
um i'm sorry that you didn't go to a
psychiatrist and you went to a hacky
comedian
instead evidently that's my fault all
right plowing ahead
um what are we up to here with time
jesus it's flying by
um girl found porn
girl found porn meets girl girl finds
porn
boy is embarrassed that's what i'm
guessing all right a few
a few years ago uh i was in a
relationship and one morning my girl
went snooping around on my computer when
i was in the shower
in a classic rookie mistake i did not
delete any of the porn sites i had
visited from my history
i'm not an internet porn addict or
anything but i am a dude
and not only do i enjoy the occasional
[ __ ] schwap session whatever that
means i guess jerking off but a lifetime
of bountiful
internet porn has made my ability to
perform the mental beat
a thing of the past i don't know what
that is
what is the mental beat
my ability to perform the mental beat a
thing of the past oh
jerking off with just your thoughts
basically i need moving pictures
i know many men understand my play yeah
dude you got to go back to that go back
to the mental [ __ ] one
you know it's a lot cheaper nobody knows
what you're thinking about
it's a safe world um anyway
she was all kinds of pissed off asked me
why i was looking at a site called you
porn while starting to cry
she was a seventh degree black belt at
the guilty crying style of fighting
meaning when she wants an instant
victory she cries and i cave
so i played the only card i could defeat
i could to defuse the situation which
was to lie
i said that a buddy sent me an email
linked to that site
because he thought he saw someone from
our high school on there she immediately
came back with
but it's in the top 10 of your most
viewed sites on your history
oh she busted you
geez you know what yeah i got to give it
up to her right there man she went
[ __ ] columbo on you and you walked
right into that
so he goes at this point i just came
clean and told her that all the dudes
still catch a beat
that all dudes catch a beat even when
they're in a relationship and it doesn't
mean that we don't find our girlfriends
desirable
i tried to make it funny and said i was
training my hogan to gain stamina
stamina so really she should be more
encouraging
that's actually funny alas she wanted
none of it
and was in total shock that i was doing
this she said that none of her previous
boyfriends ever looked at porn
let alone rub one out while in a
relationship okay
what fantasy planet does she live on um
because i then became pissed that she
would be so naive to think that that was
true
and told her that all dudes do this and
stood strong that i did nothing wrong
she can't go good for you stand in your
ground good for you
she kept coming at me with yelling
hitting and crying but i remain
unwavering in my stance and did not
apologize
looking back i think i only took this
stance because i was starting to have my
doubts in regards to the relationship
and just didn't give a [ __ ] anymore well
dude i gotta be honest with you whether
you gave a [ __ ] or didn't give a [ __ ]
about her anymore
if you totally love somebody that
doesn't mean you cave in 100
of the time you know cave in when you're
wrong you're right
sorry definitely do that [ __ ] but like
um
you know if you can't watch porn or rub
one out then i mean i i don't understand
like uh i mean it's it's a slippery
slope
starts with that and the next thing you
know you can't watch the game right
i don't [ __ ] know anyways um
turns out we broke up a few weeks later
and you better believe she threw this
incident back in my face
when she was having the goat getting
killed by a python last struggle that
you had previously made analogies about
anyways i have a new girlfriend now
which i like more but i was wondering
how i would handle the situation with
someone i really love
so what do you think the best way to
handle this situation if it happened to
you
or any other guy um
you know i don't think it's a big deal
if you're not watching it habitually if
you occasionally watch it some women
consider it cheating
um
i don't know how the [ __ ] do i well i'm
lucky nia doesn't give a [ __ ]
she doesn't care um she would care if i
hadn't done anything with her for a
while
and i was doing that that would bother
her but like she doesn't give a [ __ ]
what i do
um i think someone has to accept you for
who you are all right and unless you're
like
you know if you occasionally smoke weed
occasionally have a drink occasionally
watch porn who gives a [ __ ]
but if you're always smoking weed if
you're a [ __ ] alcoholic or you you're
you're
uh addicted to porn then i think they
that
um there's a problem but uh i would just
do what you do
you know if you think it's an issue and
you need to bring it up i would just
bring it up and say listen
uh one of my uh just let you know i
occasionally rub one out to porn
and uh my one girlfriend really had a
[ __ ] problem with it
and before we go any further i want to
make sure you you don't so there's no
any weird arguments
i'm not getting a lot of you that's not
exactly an easy thing to bring up
uh which is why you just kind of have to
be yourself in a relationship so then it
won't come out of left field because if
you're being overly polite
overly jolly overly you know just
accentuating the good parts about you
and not showing your seedier side
that really is going to come out of left
field so um does that make any sense
i would definitely i'd bring it up
you know so sweetie are we going to
dinner tonight by the way do you like
porn because i do i rub one out every
once in a while did chicks do it really
no where you going ah my [ __ ] ear is
killing me
you know my dog caused my ear to bleed
she gave my [ __ ] ear a headbutt if
you ever get a pitbull you gotta watch
out for their heads because
they're like little wrecking balls and
um
you know i hadn't been home in like a
week i was out in boston in the [ __ ]
north end
all week um by the way
underrated the north end pizzeria regina
that one seat
at the bar that faces the wall they call
it their timeout chair
you can walk right in you don't have to
stand in line if you're by yourself and
just ask if you can go sit there now
granted you have to face the wall while
everyone at the bar
shoots the [ __ ] but if you're a loner
like myself it's [ __ ] great and it's
tremendous pizza um
anyway so i had been home in like a week
so uh
you know my dog gets [ __ ] excited to
see me i'm excited to see her
neil let her out the front she's [ __ ]
jumping up and down i come through the
gate
and i had a bunch of stuff in my hand
and i kind of you know was bent
down to like hey what's up the dog
jumped up
and was like going to lick my face and
basically had its mouth kind of open and
we went
teeth to teeth to that point where i was
like did i just knock out some teeth
they definitely feel numb
fortunately she didn't so that's what
happened now you would think if
if you were a smart person you'd bring
your bags in the house where you had
your hands free and i could calm my dog
down
but i'm so [ __ ] excited to see her
and i get excited when she gets excited
i'm ah
you know i'm loving that she's it's
[ __ ] great when you come home
and there's one person like this [ __ ]
guy's home this is awesome right
so i bent down to pet her
and i was you know scratching her
ribs and she was looking down at her
tail and then she swung her head back
and i got my
[ __ ] mouth out of the way just the
last second so didn't knock my teeth out
and the side of her head slammed into
the side of mine
and basically mushed my ear i felt like
i got suckered right in this side of the
[ __ ] ear
and uh it [ __ ] bled out
i think my ear died so now i got this
[ __ ]
scab it looks like i got this big
schmutz of dirt on the side of my
[ __ ] ear for my goddamn dog
so i got the headphones on it hurts
that's why i told that story has this
podcast going off the [ __ ] rails is
it me
is it me um all right a couple of last
two uh
quick ads here and of course i can't go
back
why does it do this to me why do you do
this to me
can anybody explain why on these new
[ __ ]
macbook pros does anybody else have this
problem you go on the [ __ ] internet
and
when you go to go to a new window you
open a new tab
it won't let you go back to the other
window even though you can click on it
i don't know any nerds out there know
what the [ __ ] that's about
all right here we go let's go real quick
um amazon.com you guys know the deal if
you're gonna buy something on amazon
not saying you gotta go to billboard.com
click on the podcast page and click on
the banner ad on the right hand side the
amazon
banner ad on the right-hand side you go
to amazon go ahead and buy something it
doesn't cost you any extra money they
kicked me a percentage 10
of that i give to the wounded warriors
project you help support my podcast
and uh the troops who made an
unbelievable sacrifice for us
all right and gamefly.com
wouldn't you love to have 8 000 get
video games at your fingertips sure we
all would
um all the new hits mailed to your home
so if you're sick of paying 65
for the newest games that you or your
kids use for a week and then give
then give gamefly a shot gamefly is
offering my listeners a
free two-disc 15-day trial 23
value go to www.gamefly.com
or the gamefly banner on the on my
podcast page of the website
to redeem the offer there you go enough
with the advertising for this week back
to the shoe
all right my girls lost their mind
oh by the way everybody that was really
embarrassing last week when i thought
that that that
woman who wanted to hike was actually a
dude you know i don't know what i was
thinking i always just get emails from
guys
even when she said uh no one wants that
ghetto [ __ ] i just thought that that
was just some girl like trying to be
tough
and talking to a guy like he was a [ __ ]
i completely missed it and it was
embarrassing i got 50 emails last week
two said good podcast
and the other 48 were ridiculing me for
not realizing that
so there you go all right last couple
here and then i got to get the [ __ ]
outta e
all right my girls lost their mind
what's up bilbo i'm 25
and a few months ago i met a girl that
blew my [ __ ] mind
she was smart creative beautiful sexy
it had been over a year since the last
girl i really cared about dumped me
uh because she had a religious epiphany
and thought i was destroying her
relationship with christ
oh geez and i was beginning to think
that i'd never have that gut feeling of
love for a girl again
but this new girl but this new girl
and i oh but i met this new girl and i
started dating and things
went real fast within two weeks we were
together daily and things were great
but about a month in i began to realize
that she had a horrible temper
oh man that's brutal all right even
worse she tended to put words in my
mouth when she'd get angry
and get more mad at things i didn't even
[ __ ] say
here's an example all right this
conversation goes her him her
him her him all right i'm not gonna say
i'm not gonna all right i'll just do the
voices okay here's this example
honey what time is the movie 8 30.
i looked yesterday and i'm pretty sure
it was eight
now i just looked it up it's 8 30.
oh so so i'm stupid
what no i didn't oh so i'm stupid and
i'm a liar
jesus the only worse than her
relationship was that acting
um
i lost faith in it halfway through and
it's gotten even
extremely worse for the fourth day in a
row she's blown up at me to the point of
telling me that we should just break up
i get pissed and i'm like fine and she's
like how dare you break up with me how
could you do that yeah dude this chick
is out of her [ __ ] mind
all right she's afraid you're gonna
break up with her and she's just [ __ ]
she's [ __ ] she's sabotaging the
relationship
and guess what that's not your [ __ ]
problem all right
she can go work work out or anger with
somebody else go find someone else
you're still young
right are you still young as long as
you're not like
over 38 there's no reason to try and
wait around for this girl to [ __ ] get
her [ __ ] together
anyway she's completely in another world
and last night she told me the other
reason why
i was with her was because it was for
easy sex
[ __ ] ridiculous she text me to
apologize but ended up
oh she texted you to apologize but ended
up she started the [ __ ] all over again
when i asked her why
she'd even [ __ ] say something like
that to begin with because she's out of
her mind
all right this is your call sir
you can either date someone who's
healthy and is ready to accept you and
all the wonderful things you'll bring to
the table
um or she can go [ __ ] herself
right what
i'm sorry did that make any [ __ ]
sense that didn't did i just say that
right
i'm sorry i closed the window and then
couldn't figure out where the hell it
was
um yeah it's all up to you do you want
to deal with this [ __ ] i don't think
you do
there's plenty other great girls out
there plenty of phenomenal women
that'll be excited to be with you and
not be a complete psycho or you could
sit with this girl
and maybe she'll figure this [ __ ] out
i don't know you know what i love about
nia is she's not an angry person
okay who wants to have kids with someone
who isn't who's [ __ ] angry
oh jesus i'm glad she didn't hear that
she [ __ ] dumped me in a second
you know but i think an angry dad is
acceptable that's actually
understandable
because guys are idiots but if the mom's
angry too i just can't imagine that
i don't think that's good for kids
neither is an angry dad i guess anger in
general is not a good thing
well you know look at that i actually
learned something
um anyways um here's some stand up dates
i have coming up
i'll be at the improv in orlando florida
september 7th through the 9th and i'll
be at caroline's the rescheduled date
september 20th through the 23rd
i apologize to everybody i had to cancel
last second the uh the caroline state at
the end of july and moved to september
20th through the 23rd
i got that acting gig i can't really
tell you what it is
because uh you never know you never know
you can have a giant roll and then they
go a different direction and by the time
they're done editing
you're not even in the [ __ ] thing but
uh i got a good feeling that i'm gonna
be
um but we shall see we shall see
oh billy the actress coming around
coming around done a couple two three
things this year
uh speaking of which my favorite show
breaking bad next week
you guys might want to tune in you might
want to tune in next week
because they're always great episodes
wink wink especially when a certain
somebody
wink wink might uh be making an
appearance
hey you know what i saw a picture of one
of the most beautiful trucks i've ever
[ __ ] seen in my life
um i think i've completely abandoned
i still love cars but i am a total truck
guy now and
specifically i am a ford truck guy
from literally the 40s right through
like 1968 those are my favorite ones
i don't like the interiors on the 1970s
ford trucks i do i do love the
the front end so um
but this guy's got a 1968
uh the same year as mine f-100 with the
long bed
four-wheel drive and it is absolutely
[ __ ] gorgeous
and uh if anybody else is into trucks
i'm gonna have that up on the uh the mm
podcast page anyways
that's the podcast for this week um i
hope
this week can go by without me seeing
somebody
uh you know that i'm a fan of or even
not a fan of having to apologize for not
[ __ ] doing anything
anything wrong and i'm really sick of
just the lazy journalism while you try
to say that there's outrage when there
was no outrage
you know what i mean the joke basically
worked people
laughed it's just really [ __ ]
annoying so
anyways um that is it and by the way if
you ever see that dane is performing in
any sort of broadway thing
uh i can't recommend him highly enough i
was absolutely [ __ ]
i he blew me away and i've known this
guy for 20 [ __ ] years i've seen it
i've seen all the tricks in his [ __ ]
trick bag there and uh absolutely
[ __ ]
blew me away and i'm really happy for
him
especially after that [ __ ] [ __ ]
of that [ __ ] nerd filming him that
just really ruined my [ __ ] week
when that should you know nia actually
called me up when that happened and
like with like this concerned tone going
i know you've worked so hard what if
something you say
i mean that's the climate that's
starting to be created
which is the reason why people can't
apologize
for this [ __ ] i mean i don't know i
guess if you're on a tv show
you get pressure to do it it's all
[ __ ] they give me like the
apology isn't sincere it has to do with
money like all right
we don't want people protesting this and
making the show go away there's hundreds
of people who lose their jobs just
[ __ ] apologize
i think that's why they always go after
comedians who have like tv shows or have
some sort of notoriety have you noticed
that [ __ ]
they don't go after a guy like me what
are they gonna do
you can't stop me from telling jokes
next to a cheesecake factory in a mall
all right you could maybe turn it from a
three-quarter full room to a half-full
room but i don't give a [ __ ]
all right ah
that's just [ __ ] frustrating all
right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves i'll
talk to you next week
you